hello everybody my name is markiplier
and no I am not lying when I say that
this Baby Face gentleman that you see in
front of you is indeed the real
markiplier and when I'm unbeaten and
I've already got a little stubble
growing but when I'm unbeaten I suddenly
drop back to who I was in the year 2012
and I did this on the charity livestream
that we just did this weekend and it was
it was really fun I mean excuse also the
makeup and the gold in my hair don't
mind any of that that's coming up for a
video later this week but I just wanted
to take the time to say hi to you guys
again and I don't know I thought it was
a good opportunity to kind of
reintroduce myself because honestly I
haven't done that in a while and some of
you may wonder why I would need to
reintroduce myself but I've always felt
that it was important to do that because
it's very easy to become a caricature of
yourself and what I mean by that it's
very easy for people to assume that they
know who you are unless you keep up with
that idea and the idea of who you are is
sometimes a very hard concept to lock
down but I'll start with the basics hi
my name is Mark my middle name is Edward
my last name is Fishbach I was born on
Oahu Hawaii in Honolulu on a military
base to my dad and mom like oddly enough
that is a similar story for me as well I
was not graced upon this earth by the
gods as some people have suspected but
I'm a former biomedical engineering
student I've been doing YouTube for over
five years now and it's been an
incredible ride thus far and what really
brought this about is not only did I go
baby-faced and I I look exactly like I
did back in those days but also we
watched one of my old vlogs back on the
stream it was for my my birthday
oddly enough I just turned 23 I think
and like on that stream I said some
really silly sounding things at the time
or now they do looking back I was
talking about the statistics of the
channel I was talking about how I
decided that I wanted to be
yeah big youtuber someday when I grew up
I was going to be a big youtuber and it
was really interesting to see because at
the age of 23 like I had already like
grown up
I had already grown up at that point or
at least I thought I did until I got to
that point like I had worked an office
job I wore a tie to work every day and I
sat in a cubicle doing engineering work
and I thought that was going to be my
life and I was I was okay with that at
the time and then I found something else
that led me into doing YouTube and I can
talk about that or you can watch some
videos that I've made in the past to
talk about that but long story short I
had a medical problem I had a tumor I
got that removed and that led me to
trying to make videos for a living and
it worked it really did and five years
later I have had more success than I
could ever hope for and in the journey
we've managed to build one of the
greatest communities I've ever seen
anywhere and I am so incredibly proud of
what you guys have done and I'm so
incredibly incredibly proud of you guys
joining us for these streams every
single weekend and I'm so incredibly
proud of you guys continuing to champion
the causes that we talk about because
it's not just about the fact that we're
able to raise more money than ever
before and and I don't know the final
count from this weekend but I'll let you
guys know as soon as I find that out but
it's not just about that it's not just
about us having these live streams every
month and that's the end of it it's the
fact that it echoes beyond what we do on
that day like the the resounding success
of those live streams come yes from the
donations being made in the tangible
good that you see out of that but also
from how it affects other people that
want to do those things the ripple that
it has and I'm not there saying like I'm
not taking credit for any of this
because I've always said that it's you
guys that managed to do it and it's the
community the rallies around what we do
but
it's so amazing to see it ripple and
continue and inspire generations to come
to do these amazing things and to raise
money for charity and go out there and
try to change the world and coming from
the perspective of reintroducing you
myself to you guys is the idea of what I
want to be when I grow up and that
sounds like a silly thing to say but
it's true like what do I want to be when
I grow up because I've only been doing
this for five years I'm 27 years old
which is old by some standards but if
you ask anyone older than me I'm still
incredibly young and I mean even looks
it right that would by baby face but I'm
still incredibly young and I have so
many other ambitions for what I want to
do and it all revolves around this
incredible community that we have here
and I am so so excited like every day
I'm excited for the future every day I'm
excited for what's to come every day I'm
excited to to make new challenges for
myself and exceed them or not meet them
or fail and try again but never stop
creating you know in the endeavor and
that's one of the most beautiful things
that I can see coming out of the
community is creation like you guys
going out there and making things
starting your own channels and starting
your own art projects and finding new
ways to blaze your trail and go out
there and and I see that as just a
little piece of what I did in the
beginning of all this craziness and I'm
really happy I don't know I'm just
really happy to be here and and to
admittedly things have been crazy on my
end because we've been moving offices
because like we said on the stream in
case you missed it the last topic that
we had it was very nice looking but he
was horrifying like every single area in
that office was horror like there was a
bug wall where bugs would you start
crawling out of the wall at random you
never
no one a centipede was about to coming
out of there there was a wall that not
only flooded but any computer equipment
that you would ever put in that corner
would die inevitably we went through
three different computers we resurrected
a computer twice and put it back in the
same computer corner and it just blew up
each and every time it just blew up we
have no idea why so it's been crazy
trying to move offices to this new one
then we're going to get it set up for
the next dream real nice and you're
going to see that but just thank you
guys thank you guys for holding on to
the hope that we can make the world a
better place and if I had to summarize
what I want to be when I grow up it
would be I want to change the world I
don't just want to make a small impact
on the world I want to change the world
and I can't do that alone I never could
I never would be able to do that alone
but now in this community I have an
opportunity and I have a responsibility
to guide you guys and hopefully point
you guys are in the right direction and
even if it comes down to the point where
I am not the one who's guiding you and
it's you who's guiding me then that's
what it comes to but either way I want
to change the world I want to make a
lasting impact on hopefully for the
better by the way this is all for the
better not saying change the world for
the worst
but change the world for the better and
make a difference today and tomorrow and
and we talked about it on the stream and
the idea that we'll make changes that
ripple beyond our own lives that when
our time comes and goes we'll know
the generations that follow us will
follow in our footsteps and be able to
lead themselves down a path to a
brighter future and that is a beautiful
idea and that's what I want in these
silly videos I make and I make silly
videos come something more profound and
more amazing than I could have ever
hoped for so just thank you everybody so
much for watching I don't think I'm
going to keep the baby face I I do like
the beard we did it for a very specific
reason that you're going to see very
soon and probably this Friday I believe
but it's really really really cool to be
in the middle of the most amazing time
in my life and I believe I'm in the
middle of it because it's it's
astonishing it really is the things that
I can do now and the things that we can
do together and I'm grateful for that
every single day so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
bye bye bye